1 2 3
[Musique]
bonjour madame êtes-vous sur facebook
oui vous étiez sur facebook
oui Facebook non pourquoi Facebook non
et je préfère que c'est plus amusant que
facebook on a l'impression que tout a
commencé entre guillemets avec facebook
ensuite il y a eu la génération un petit
peu Instagram et pour aller un peu plus
jeune et puis TikTok pour aller encore
un peu plus jeune c'est un petit peu
l'impression que j'ai il a des
informations sur cette plateforme là et
sur TikTok qu'est-ce que ça vous
inquiète
la mauvaise information ça va influencer
des gens puis c'est pas tout le monde
qui va aller chercher la crédibilité de
l'information donc ça peut influencer
des mauvais comportements ou des fausses
idées beaucoup de fois Instagram
Facebook juste disent que
ce qui est mis en ligne n'est pas
correct mais ils font pas assez pour
démontrer
sur quel point ils sont pas vrai ou ce
qui est faux vous trouvez pas que c'est
la responsabilité de ces plateformes de
nous fournir les outils les moyens
nécessaires à notre portée pour qu'on
puisse nous-mêmes en tant qu'utilisateur
valider les contenus la qualité des
contenus je pense que si mais je vois
pas comment il pourrait mettre ça en
place
oui c'est un sujet complexe en effet si
le moins qu'on puisse dire surtout sur
une plateforme comme Tic-Toc qui a le
vent dans les voiles et dont les
utilisateurs sont de plus en plus
exposés à la désinformation c'est ce
qu'on avait d'ailleurs constaté l'an
dernier quand Jeff et Nicolas avait
testé l'efficacité de l'algorithme de
TikTok capable de servir rapidement le
profil des utilisateurs pour ensuite
leur suggérer des contenus trompeurs ou
carrément faux depuis ma ce risque s'est
amplifié alimenté par une hausse
fulgurante de la popularité de cette
plateforme qui a des jouets bien des
pronostics
[Musique]
Jeff il y a à peu près un an tout juste
on entreprenait la troisième saison des
décrypteurs en parlant de TikTok qui
avait dans le vent dans les voiles grâce
notamment à son algorithme très puissant
et redoutable là un an plus tard ou en
est
l'ascension fulgurante de secteur a
continué je pense qu'on avait vu juste
si on s'était trompé c'était peut-être
de pas voir la vitesse de bien saisir la
vitesse à laquelle Tic-Toc allait donner
de plus en plus dominant donc on sent
dans la dernière année quelque chose qui
a changé donc on dirait que l'étoile de
Facebook en tant que réseau social de
référence peut-être pas aller un peu
c'est pas pour dire que Facebook
[Musique]
a toujours plus de 2 milliards
d'utilisateurs mensuels actif mais on
voit que on reçoit moins de signalements
de la part des lecteurs de publication
Facebook des fois on voit que les choses
qui circulent sur Facebook sur Twitter
sont des vidéos de TikTok on voit que
Tic-Toc attire pendant des jeunes mais
un public de plus en plus large et on
sent qu'il y a quelque chose qui se
trame qu'il y a peut-être un changement
de garde dans dans le sens que Tik Tok
va peut-être prendre le dessus même sur
les autres réseaux sociaux on le sentait
l'année passée mais là on dirait que ça
va plus vite et puis c'est encore plus
important comme phénomène est-ce que
c'est un phénomène qui mesure et ce que
tu nous décris le seul changement de
tendance là est-ce qu'on le voit j'ai vu
un graphique qui est quand même
intéressant de la part
d'un site web qui s'appelle No yearning
donc c'est en quelque sorte une
encyclopédie des mimes sur internet donc
on a souvent parlé à l'émission de ces
images à caractère humoristique ou qui
font réfléchir qui lance toutes sortes
de messages politisés moins politisés
des images vidéos c'est des idées que
les gens copient remixent à leur façon
et les ballons sur le web donc non il
m'a fait un graphique où on montre la
provenance des mines de 2011 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui donc les plateformes qui ont
donné naissance aux mines donc on voit
que par exemple en 2011 la ligne jaune
c'est YouTube donc près de 40% des mines
sur Internet provenait de YouTube on
voit qu'aujourd'hui c'est rendu à 13 14
% j'attire l'attention sur la courbe de
Tik Tok qui part de zéro ça c'est la
mauve ici qui est à 0 à 18 par 2 0 à
2018 maintenant c'est la plateforme
numéro 2 en terme de création de mime
sur Internet Twitter est encore la
plateforme ou les mines mais c'est entre
la tendance
donc on voit que un influence de plus en
plus importante sur la culture du web 6
Tik Tok vous deviez en effet le moteur
de création culturel sur Internet ben on
va y passer c'est certain que il y a des
choses qui vont se glisser là-dedans qui
sont pas nécessairement très positive
disons bah oui c'est sûr Jeff on le voit
on l'observé de plus en plus la désinfos
circule sur TikTok on peut
raisonnablement prévoir que ça va
continuer dans ce sens là alors si on
ramène ça sur nous puisqu'on patrouille
le web pour dénicher la désinfos jusqu'à
quel point c'est facile de surveiller ce
qui se passe sur Tik Tok par rapport à
j'ai pas Facebook l'exemple classique
c'est un nouveau défi
bon Facebook a été critiqué maintes fois
pour son opacité de son algorithme
d'avoir permis à toutes sortes de choses
de circuler sur la plateforme il y a
quand même des outils qui sont
disponibles il y a aussi certaines
fonctionnalités de transparence qui sont
aussi très utiles mais par exemple on a
un souci
qui a été acheté par Facebook il y a
quelques années mais ça permet de voir
ce qui circule sur facebook donc par
exemple ici on a toutes les publications
au cours des trois derniers jours les
plus populaires au Québec donc carrément
on peut voir
les choses les plus populaires sur les
réseaux sociaux on peut effectuer des
recherches avec des mots clés on peut
écrire par exemple vaccin un exemple
comme ça un exemple complètement
aléatoire et on peut voir bon c'est quoi
les publications qui parlent de vaccin
les plus populaires donc ça ça peut être
très utile pour des gens comme nous qui
de surveiller ce qui est curieux sur le
web d'autres choses qui est possible sur
Facebook par exemple
j'utilise l'exemple ici de la page de
Radio-Canada information supposons qu'on
sait pas c'est quoi Radio-Canada
information qu'on a jamais vu cette page
là ben il y a quand même
l'onglet transparence qui est quelque
chose qui a été ajouté il y a quelques
années par facebook qui permet de voir
que des informations de base que la page
est gérée par des gens qui habitent au
Canada on peut aller voir la banque
publicitaire donc on peut voir les
publicités qui sont diffusées par cette
tâche Facebook là si c'est des
publicités qui sont politiques par
exemple on a accès au budget qui était
loué à l'auditoire qui est visé toutes
sortes de données comme ça mais ce sont
des choses qui sont très utiles pour
nous l'un de savoir que qui gère la page
de ça me donne une idée de qui est
derrière ça qui finance ça certains
ça nous donne pas toujours toute
l'information qu'on veut
ça peut donner des indices d'aller
déterminer
qui se trouve derrière une page Facebook
aussi un autre chose utile qui est qu'on
utilise souvent c'est un autre
application de planter qui permet de
voir supposons avec un article toutes
les personnes qui ont partagé sur le web
dont d'aller voir sur qui a partagé
cette article sur facebook combien
d'interactions ça générée c'est pas pour
dire que Facebook est parfait en matière
de transparence mais on a quand même
accès à une boîte à outils qui nous
permet de bien faire notre travail de
capable de non seulement mesurer la
viralité des choses qui circulent sur le
web mais aussi les tracks ça c'est pour
Facebook tic-tac disons que la boîte à
outils est moins garnie en ce moment Tik
Tok c'est un autre univers complètement
c'est moins basé sur les comptes
auxquels on est abonné même si ça influe
ce qu'on voit sur TikTok c'est plus un
flux d'informations de contenu qui est
infini qui est complètement différent de
de Facebook par exemple nous on a une
vidéo ici on ne sait pas quand est-ce
que ça a été publié il y a pas de date
il y a pas de date
on voit que que il y a beaucoup
d'interactions donc 16 millions de
j'aime
84000 commentaires donc on sait que
c'est quelque chose qui est assez viral
mais qui le regardait qui le repartagait
c'est assez difficile à déterminer
si on clique sur le compte qui a diffusé
la vidéo ben on n'a pas beaucoup
d'informations on sait qu'il y a 3,8
millions d'abonnés ce qui est quand même
appréciable mais contrairement Facebook
on peut pas savoir quand la page a été
créée ou la personne est basée dans quel
pays ce genre de choses il y a aucune
transparence
on ne pas accès à des outils comme
karting goal comme je montrais
qui montre le c'est quoi les choses les
plus virales en ce moment voyage la
plateforme exactement qu'est-ce qui
prend la pression suffisante sur Tik Tok
pour que des mesures mises en place je
pense que Tik Tok n'y échappera pas donc
faut se rappeler les outils que Facebook
a aidé à mettre au point les fonctions
de transparence comme la banque
publicitaire et l'emplacement des gens
qui cherchent une page de Facebook ça ça
a été créé en réponse à des pressions
dans le fond pour permettre aux gens
d'avoir une meilleure idée de ce qui se
passe sur la plateforme d'avoir une plus
grande transparence mais je pense que
c'est inévitable dans le sens que là à
mesure qu'une plateforme commence à
atteindre des centaines de millions de
gens il y a des gens qui vont réaliser
qui peuvent utiliser Tic-Toc à mauvaise
escient et puis quand les acteurs
malveillants vont comprendre ça et
commencer à se lancer dans TikTok
va avoir les mêmes pressions qu'on subit
le Facebook et Twitter il y a 5-6 ans
Tik Tok est une entreprise qui est
détenue par une entreprise chinoise
c'est pour ça que certains ont des
doutes sur la capacité de Tik Tok de
réellement mettre en place des
mécanismes de transparence on associe
pas la Chine à la transparence non puis
on a vu qu'il y a eu des enjeux de
modération par exemple des vidéos qui
parlaient de la minorité ouigo en Chine
qui avait été retiré
Tic-Toc quand même des politiques de
modération assez strictes en matière de
sexualité ce qui plaît pas à certains
créateurs LGBT par exemple donc
devient la plateforme
dominante c'est sûr et certain qu'ils
vont faire face aux mêmes questions là
c'est un peu de pâté pour Tic-Toc c'est
un peu comme facebook en 2014 ou tout va
bien la croissance est incroyable tout
le monde utilise ça beaucoup d'argent
qui génèrent mais il y a des lendemain
de veille qui est
peut-être quelqu'un qui va sonner la
cloche pour la récréation fini